[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
but
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
more
let's do
okay
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
do
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
all right um we're gonna get started
i'm gonna ask everybody to repeat after
me please
adam we love you
we will not stop
until there is justice for you
[Applause]
elizabeth we love you
we stand with you we will fight for
justice for your son
thank you everybody
we're gonna get some safety
announcements before
um just to make sure that everybody uh
knows this information please please
please pay attention
hello everyone my name is stefan cuevas
guano i am queer i am
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we're here to defund the police until
they are abolished
before we do that we need to go over
some safety
right to make sure that community is
safe that we are all safe
because police do not keep us safe who
keeps us safe
absolutely so we need to do some safety
things but before we do
i want to recognize the organizations
and folks
who have organized this action here
today this action was organized mostly
by fans
mostly by queer folks and mostly by
trans folks
[Applause]
[Music]
good kids mass city chicago freedom
school
cicero community farm little village
community council and
royal as well as many individuals who
are part of this movement
so what we need to do to keep us safe is
we need to center
the voice of the speakers most of the
people speaking today will be
youth of color they will be survivors
and they will be people who are directly
impacted by police brutality and state
oppression
so we are going to center their voices
today we are not centering politicians
we are not censoring state officials i
know a lot of politicians and state
officials came to us once this action
was done
and asked hey can we speak and we're
like why would we let you didn't do
anything you didn't do any of the work
we brought our waters here we bought our
medical supplies
another thing is white allies don't
instigate we want to make sure
five poc are safe during this protest
i know if pensions are high but white
folks please do not
instigate with the police um because
it's usually people of color queer trans
folks
who are who have the repercussions of a
lot of your anger
so we need to center them please do not
antagonize the police please do not talk
to the police
so along with that is do not police help
by poc protest
if we're laughing if we're crying if
we're shouting at the police
please do not tell us how we're supposed
to feel and mourn and grieve
um safe distance we are in a pandemic
please wear a mask over your nose please
stay
six feet apart hand sanitizer marshalls
we'll have some people will walk around
with some
please uh follow that because it is
people of color who are
mostly impacted by the coronavirus right
now so we need to keep those
folks safe uh follow the organizers
leads
right so we're the organizers people on
the stage or the organizers please
listen to us
uh we are trying to keep everyone safe
here we have a route we have a plan
we have people who are uplifting us and
helping us please listen to us we only
want what's best for the community here
um and i'm gonna pass it on to there we
go thank you so much
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
oh
[Music]
so
um
hey everyone my name is karina i
organized with unite and as of recently
a collective of other organizations
that stephan mentioned such as el vejo
12 word ipo
chicago freedom school royal community
cicero community farm good kids met city
justice chicago
we want to thank the organizations who
offered their help out today
and of course to all the individuals
thank you so much for coming out here
and being with us in community
this morning i was reading messages from
people who reached out um
from like hope church the comfort
station grace church and i got really
emotional because
i thought people would be scared of us
i thought that the people would be doing
what they do downtown and like boarding
everything up
um so it made me really emotional that
they opened their doors for us today if
anybody needs to use the restroom charge
their phones or get some snacks they've
they've offered to open their doors for
us
last year people were stuck downtown
property than us
in preparation for today people reached
out to offer rides
so that people could get home safe so
don't hesitate to let one of our
our organizers know so that we can put
you in contact with someone and get you
home safe
okay
[Music]
it's really really powerful that we're
all here in community
because capitalism thrives off of
breaking
communities it thrives off of creating
fear
amongst all of us and what happens when
we fear each other
we project we become judgey and we turn
on each other
the state wants us to be in this state
of fear and disconnection from each
other
really really [ __ ] up that people
published
since debating the chicago police
department killing a child
it ain't right that ain't right
there are people who are silent victim
blaming telling lies
or even still calling for reform
it's disappointing but not surprising
that a lot of these people
are elected officials so let's call them
out
laurie lightfoot alderman george
cardenas
call him out call him out
[Music]
that's one of my favorite songs
y'all do anything but listen to the
youth
the youth who've been putting in actual
work in their communities
genuine care and connection
not just to get a vote or a photo up
you're not listening we're saying defund
the police
abolish the police fund us
fund our community
we need rent control good
jobs our covered relief funds
it's not right for the police to get so
much funding
and 280 million dollars of our covet
relief funds
[Applause]
that ain't right
even before the pandemic people's basic
needs were not being met
people don't have clean air housing
security
food security equitable funding for our
schools
people are not safe from the police
this is state violence
we say again police you are not
judge jury and executioner
we demand justice for adam
soledo
a 13 year old boy he should still be
alive
nothing nothing nothing nothing excuses
cpd having shots and killed him
nobody deserves to die at the hands of
the police but especially
not kids we don't need to see the video
to know that adam deserves to live
[Applause]
the police the police has a
long history of corruption
and cover-ups and they expect us to
trust them
in the last few in the last weeks alone
it's been lie
after lie after lie
[Music]
justice for mark nevada who was also
killed by the chicago police department
justice for anthony alvarez yes
yes justice for dante wright
justin for brianna
for taylor floyd
and countless other victims of police
violence
countless others those are the ones that
we know of
imagine the ones that we don't know
about
there are no excuses there are no
good cops there is
[Music]
there is no reforming the police
where do we want abolition when do we
want it now
we could all say what we said in the
beginning louder please
adam we love
[Applause]
not you we will not stop
until there is justice for you until
there is justice for you
elizabeth we love you we love you
we stand with you we stand with you and
we will fight for justice for
your son and we will fight for judgment
we need you
we love you we love you
adam
thank you everybody
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
me
[Music]
ah
thank you
[Music]
oh
[Music]
all right guys i'm gonna introduce are
from justice for families
[Music]
hey y'all there's police trying to
infiltrate please do not
let them into the crowd please do not
talk to them
please be safe but do not let them into
here they were not
invited to be here
[Music]
justice for
[Applause]
had to make families some bullet points
for today
because um so much is going through my
mind and through my heart but first of
all to the
adam toledo family i sent you much
love because i've been in your shoes
my 16 year old nephew was shot and
killed by police
on april 11 2016 in north london
and when i saw what happened to that
baby it was so reminiscent
of what happened to my nephew and i was
like
no matter all the work we're doing i'm
like here we go again i'm like they're
not hearing us
they're not understanding what we're
saying to them about how they
operate themselves in our communities
so i i normally don't even watch the
videos
i i haven't even really fully watched my
nephew's video although we didn't have
body camera
uh but i watched because
i'm the co-chair of the youth supports
working group and next week
we are working on foot pursuit because
right now
the chicago police department does not
have a football food policy
and this had nothing to do with lori
lightfoot the coalition members gave
cpd and the city a foot pursue policy
back in 2017
after so many young black and brown
lives were being taken
after foot pursuits so
um the mayor sold us a war ticket
you know to me anyway i know i voted for
her
because i thought she said
i know i heard somebody say you know
[ __ ] reform but
if we don't get in their rooms and get
any businesses and get in their heads we
cannot leave them unchecked on our
streets
so to me it's just a measure before the
abolishment comes
that's what time that is and that's what
we're doing
the reason why the officer worked on
that young man
is because they did not work on my
nephew and i made it their business to
know that you cannot leave our young
people out here dying on the streets
and so that's what they are made to do
now they have to render first aid until
the first responders come
they let my nephew die not only did they
not help him
they wouldn't let the paramedics help
him
while they gave a public apology we got
nothing
we never got nothing from the city and
no one else
so it's important that impacted voices
be in these rooms and in these
conversations
and leading the way and trying to make
some change somewhere
and it's still dark as hell and we're
still hurting
and i just want to say to the family how
this goes
anytime there's any reference of a gun
we all saw the video
we we know we all saw it regardless of
what they tried to tell us we saw what
we saw
period copa is going to justify it
kim fox raggedy ass gonna come behind
copa
she's going to just yes have forensics
did because she can't trust them
period at all
i want to say something about the
ultimate
of that ward alderman rodriguez
he came out and spoke and caught it
murder
no other argument i've seen since this
happened to my nephew i ain't saying
that i don't say
nothing no nothing y'all want gotta
commend him and work with him
because he came out and he said it they
all got their hands so far
laurie's ass they don't work for lori
they work for us
and they ain't saying nothing
support the family y'all we gotta do
more than this sometime y'all
really gotta wrap around some of this
work cause there's so much work to be
done
whether you writing a poem or doing
something on social media planning did
whatever you do we need the support we
need to keep this going we need to keep
this momentum going
we got to keep this pressure on them
because just when we think we get that
numbers down at one point
at the lacroix mcdonald we got their
numbers down to single digits
now they're going back up again and
we're wondering what is going on
are they not seeing what's going on
around the nation
are we calling for the same thing all
around the nation
and they still doing the same things to
us
they talked to a lieutenant from the a
retired lapd officer
on the news and they asked her what did
she think when she saw the video
and they always wanted to get some
cheerleaders and [ __ ] but what she said
was
i wish that adam had gotten the same
consideration
that a 13 year old white boy would have
[Applause]
got
and i just want to say one more thing
about what happened to my nephew
so after he was killed you know the
first thing they do is go denigrating
your loved one and your family they go
all back into history they went back
talk about my niece when she was in high
school and [ __ ]
what they got to do with anything that's
what they do
but the only thing we get about the
officer is how long has raggedy has been
on the force
and what kind of accommodation is he to
make they never tell you none of that
backstory because trust me they have
them
and what we need to keep our eyes on is
how many killer cops
are still in our communities and i'm
like if y'all hadn't killed over here
why they still over here why is the
officer that killed my nephew still on
the west side
get him from over here because this is a
small
area move him somewhere else
but the 11th district has a lot of
killer cops
it's like they said where's this the
graveyard for killer cops they're on the
west side
deep that's where they put them after 30
days death duty
they move them to your community right
back to where they
started the [ __ ] at and that's
problematic
and the other thing is he's been
promoted
he's been made a detective with the
trial pending
what kind of job do you want where you
didn't kill somebody
you have a child pending for murder and
your job promotes you
that means they're condoning his
behavior they're condoning what he did
y'all gotta watch preacher sister
and john cat and zara president
of the fraternal order of police awesome
he talked [ __ ] about me he said i should
resign
from the use of force working group i
said [ __ ] have to fight me for it
you have to fight me for you i'll meet
you on the street you want me i'll give
it up
but i knew that wasn't gonna happen
[Applause]
and i'm like why are they letting him
say anything he doesn't even have any
police power
he was stripped of his police power
badge and gun because he's a liar
and he's on television talking about
smug and crafts when somebody
lost that baby and he on telling me they
already told me it was justified how can
you say that
you neanderthal you monster
so
the other thing the last thing i want to
say about when my nephew was killed
within minutes minutes i counted them
there were over a hundred police
officers over a hundred
police officers in that area you mean to
tell me a hundred police officers cannot
apprehend a sixteen-year-old
130 pound boy
so many names rashad mcintosh
betty jones quintonio legrill laquon
mcdonald
harith augustus
ron o'neill joshua
stills it's so many names and it hurts
so bad
well thank you all for letting me have
this moment but i leave you with the
spirit of understanding
with compassion i leave you with love i
leave you a peace
i leave you a purpose i leave you with
solidarity i leave you with power
and most of i all you with
fearlessness because you can't be afraid
to do this work
because so many families have had this
happen to
them and they have been in the shadows
playing out of fear
of what the do to them but i'm telling
you come out cause them days are over
those days are long gone we are here now
we ain't going nowhere
[ __ ] 12.
what do we want what do we want it
what do we want what do we want it
if we don't get it if we don't get it
if we don't get it we don't get it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
wow
love the energy um we're gonna hear
from krista from justice for families
hola
there's some [ __ ] right
[Applause]
hands up don't shoot
why are we standing here
while she was walking door
[Music]
and then
you go around
while you kill grandmother
while you kill young women and men while
you killed old women
you kill all of y'all
calling yourselves the police talking
about
serving and protecting y'all kill
a thousand people per year
1 000 people per year
across this nation and who's okay with
this
who's okay with this y'all okay with
this
hell no hell no
why do they continue to get away why do
they
to get away with you know why
we ain't united but what are we doing
what are we today
what are we today
what are we today
[Music]
can you
[Music]
hey
this is
[Music]
[Applause]
we must stay together
we got to fill this
[Music]
they don't care they don't care if you
don't give a [ __ ] i don't even know why
we just stopped
they will kill you for no good reason
because
[Applause]
we got to get together
and we got to stay together
every day
every time every time
us to meet y'all again we can meet y'all
here every time
[Music]
damn video
what's that what about
okay we have to stop this they can't be
announcing it like
legends
you know what this is lynching they put
the people to sleep when they do that
they're busting in lynching homes
snatching us out of our homes and we
don't belong here
they gotta ship us back somewhere
this is america and this is a whole
[Applause]
continent
[Applause]
hello
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so i'm telling y'all unless we unite
they're gonna continue make not feel
safe somewhere we've been it's the
beginning of time
[Applause]
no we didn't
we thought
that we will unite forever
i am
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
reminding us that with unity
anything is possible ain't no power like
the power of the people don't stop
oh
[Music]
[Music]
to protect people
from them protected
listen to the marshall
[Applause]
i don't know that cpd just [ __ ] up
[ __ ] everything
we have here a survivor
by the chicago police officers under the
command of john burge
so please welcome mark clements
make some noise out here
[Music]
you know there's no other way
to describe this story
and before you take these media cameras
you make sure that you go back
and you tell the mayor of the city of
chicago
that she covered up
murder
[Applause]
what i watch it traumatized me
it traumatized me
self being 16 years old taken to a
police station
having my genitals and my testicles
grabbed and squeezed
and no one believing me for decades
i sit behind a prison wall
if you ever have known me
i send all of you media
requests you know why
your daddy locked up in prison yo uncle
locked up in prison your cousin locked
up in prison
your neighbor locked up in prison
what happened to this 13 year old child
adam you
make sure this echoes all
across this globe
[Applause]
kim fox kim fox
saw tony over here earlier
get your ass up and charge that goddamn
officer
for the murder of this young kid
you ask little people like me
to give you an opportunity to come into
office
and to do what's right you have allowed
police officers to traumatize us
even once leaving the prisons
you have shed your ears
to these brothers and these sisters that
are being gunned down
in the middle of the street still today
over 100 torture victims
still sit inside of a prison while they
play political football
[Music]
i say enough is enough
on that ain't right
as being a resident of the 12th
ward i call for
every [ __ ] official
that is a part of this
investigation and to sit your asses
down and to come out
with the right goddamn choice these
people are not out here
because they believe this child
was mistreated we're out here because we
watched
a child gunned down by the damn
chicago police that's what happened to
that child
where is the integrity where
is the integrity
in closing i want this whole park
to rock i want this whole park
to rock we showing laurie lightweight
no more we showing the governor no more
we showing tony practical no more
we saw the criminal justice system no
more
hey guess what make some noise
[Applause]
calm dark over at that cook county jail
calm dark resign
you put people inside of those tails
and guess what you touch your head you
let them die
of covert 19. guess what tom
just like we got rid of anita alvarez
bye
[Applause]
one more time for mark london
[Music]
[Applause]
all
[Music]
please please get off the stage it's
becoming a safety
[Music]
issue
thank you everyone if you're not one of
the families
up here please step off the stage
all right i'm going to introduce
somebody else
so um you know a lot of us have been
thinking of elizabeth adam toledo's
mother who lost her son we have here
another mother she lost her son in
october of 2020
mark nevadas
so if you could please come up here
that time is now i know the mother is
probably grieving and we need time to
grieve
but we also need justice and we need it
now
there's no reason why a mother should be
burying
her kid there's no reason
i don't care what everyone said
it was hard for me because it hasn't
been a year
and we're always hiding behind closed
doors
enough is enough
[Music]
there's no way a reason why i should be
going to the cemetery every day
why i don't have blankets
why do they do this to us give
all these kids an opportunity to live
to make the wrong right don't be the
jury and judge
before they even get arrested
before they even get in front of a judge
everybody decides to be judging
adam anthony mark anthony
don't be a judge let them go to court
arrest them defend themselves we need
justice please do not murder them i
didn't know illinois had the death
penalty
do you have it now
what is going on is cpd now
the death penalty
we have the death penalty preacher
sister
we do not creature let them go to court
do not
shoot these kids let them live
let them bury the parents not the
parents they the kids
we need justice and we need it now
[Applause]
what do we want what do we want it
what do we want
[Applause]
[Music]
if we don't get it
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
hmm
[Applause]
right here
we also have anthony
[Applause]
hello everyone um i'm anthony's
cousin um i
actually shared a little bit of our
story last time
i was still very very devastated that i
couldn't even speak
up very clearly today i'm more so here
to tell y'all that we can't even get a
[ __ ] break from these cops
our family was trying to say our last
goodbyes to anthony this past weekend
and none of us wanted any interviews
anymore we just wanted
to say goodbye to him you know and move
forward
i can't imagine being in any of this
mother's position
when i saw the video it gave our family
hella strength to show up here today
in front of all of you guys
during the funeral and the bureau of my
cousin we were just trying to say our
last goodbyes
during that those two days those cubs
were already
already getting in contact with the
media saying don't even bother with that
family anthony didn't even have family
this is his family we are his family
and the whole world is going to know his
name
but we also want to know the name of
that card that saw him not one time in
the leg
multiple times because that's not what
he said on the article that came out
first on abc7 in the article
and i have it right here on my phone it
says he was shot on the leg
it was a confrontation there was no
confrontation and when my
when my tia went and confirmed the body
my my aunt
when my aunt went and confirmed the body
it was most
they didn't even show her the lower body
it was just the the upper body and it
was two shots so it was not one shot it
was multiple
so we want answers we want to know the
name of that cop
and i appreciate you everyone for being
here and i don't i appreciate the toledo
family like i said
for giving us that strength to not give
up and to keep fighting
for the justice of all of these souls
that we lost
all of these young people and all of the
future generations
i don't really have anything else that i
want that i can say right now like i
said i wasn't very prepared because
my family was already like you know what
let's just drop it but this is not the
end of us we're going to keep fighting
too to get those videos
[Applause]
we're going to get those videos we're
going to get the name and we're going to
get justice for anthony and
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
right
solo
oh city
[Music]
all right um next up
we have a youth organizer and this was
also mark davaris's best friend
please welcome anderson
[Applause]
we gotta remember a lot of these police
officers that work in our community do
not understand our community
that a lot of the police officers that
work in our community
do not understand our community
so when we say we say [ __ ] some of these
white ass cops don't understand what
we're see
to the nearest cop to you and say [ __ ]
the police
[ __ ] the police [ __ ] the police
[ __ ] the police
[Music]
[ __ ] the police this is not
an event justice is a process
i need we got i'm not good with math but
i know we got a couple hundred
[ __ ] here
i need everybody that's here today
once you leave this protest because it's
not a [ __ ] event
take this [ __ ] with you wherever you go
[Music]
a lot of y'all waiting for this video to
come out i didn't [ __ ] watch the
video
i didn't watch the video i've been ready
to throw down for adam from dave [ __ ]
one
[Music]
[Applause]
but no now we got the video out right
so nobody here and outside of this
[ __ ] circle
has an excuse not to throw down for adam
[Applause]
when they killed when they killed miguel
and pelson
they said he shot at the police when
they killed my best friend mark
in october they said he was
he had a gun and it was an armed
encounter
when they killed adam they got no
[ __ ] excuse and nobody here has an
excuse not to get down for adam
[Applause]
it's a couple people if you want to know
what what you can do
there's a couple people that we need to
be that we need to be holding
accountable
for those of you from the little village
area even if you don't live in a little
village if you're close to little
village
george cardenas is blaming adam for his
own murder
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
are we gonna let that ride
[Music]
hell now
is blaming adam for his own murder are
we going to let that ride
[Applause]
hell no
choi garcia our progressive from little
village
[Music]
is [ __ ] silent right now he's [ __ ]
silent
why because he loves the police he
supports the police
where is chewie garcia when we're having
a real conversation
about police killing children in our
community
there's too many people to call out for
me to even list them out right now
so don't think that because you came to
this protest that you did something for
adam
hell no when you leave here you better
be getting down for adam
when you see the captain up you better
call that [ __ ]
they made an excuse for killing miguel
they made an excuse for killing mars
they have no excuse for adam no excuse
so take this [ __ ] with you the hundreds
of people that are here take this [ __ ]
with you we don't need you to just be
coming to rallies
we need you to take this [ __ ] with you
everywhere you go when you see something
hold that [ __ ] out pull out your
camera and start recording and call that
[ __ ] out
[Applause]
in fact why are these
police officers not being prosecuted
i said this at the last march why didn't
we get an email burst out
for what 16 shots in the two barrels
[Music]
up
one shot gonna cover up one shot and a
cover
up one shot and a cover up everybody
here has a job
everybody here has a [ __ ] job
if you know anybody making excuses for
having fun
you have a [ __ ] job if you run into
georgetown show that [ __ ] help
me get down
you don't kill one of us and that
[ __ ] plane for 13 years
we need community control of the police
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if um have a fight whether you're a
martial or not
please stay on the side so that we can
protect people
in the middle of the marshals
make sure knocking down people
please
okay
[Music]
[Music]
no justice
[Music]
oh
[Music]
so
[Music]
okay
you know
[Music]
oh
you
oh
[Applause]
oh
uh
for
be at the sure
oh
everybody
but it's not a show it's not a
choreography
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
checking
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
so
hello
uh
[Applause]
okay
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
18 miles
before he got
hello
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
peace
no peace no peace
no justice
oh
huh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
audrey
they should be friends today
three
yeah you found them
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Applause]
[Music]
wow
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
hello
[Music]
oh
so
[Music]
oh
[Music]
please
[Music]
don't shoot
[Music]
to the front the family
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
everybody stopped
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
we are doing this together we don't have
to run over the women
let's protect our women
if you don't do nothing else pay
attention to
[Applause]
remember we're moving slow we're here
together don't run over each other
and let's please protect our women we
don't need to shove them
let's protect our women today is the day
to listen to each other
especially the women
ready
[Music]
oh
[Music]
how many people do you feel today
[Applause]
no justice
[Music]
the people united will never be defeated
united will never be defeated
united will never be defeated
from the west side to the south cp
we brought you out from the south side
[Music]
[ __ ]
[Applause]
[Music]
trayvon martin
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
cbp
is
you want to
for me
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
kill the police
[Music]
they stop and they search me
[Music]
what do we want what do we wanted
no justin
[Music]
bieber
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
today
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey how many kids
[Music]
me
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
firefighters
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
justice
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
three
[Music]
three
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey
uh
[Applause]
how is it that the police are going to
shoot him when he didn't have no weapon
he was he he had his hands up as you
[Music]
instead of the gun
[Music]
in chicago right now there's a lot of
violence there's a lot of that
they they they talk to us they know the
way we dress
it doesn't matter the way we dress yeah
don't discriminate the way we
look it just can't be like that
it's always somebody has to say
you're you're something like this you're
a bad influence it's how we're raised
it doesn't matter with the night we do
not come from a good community
we were we were raised either poor rich
however it doesn't matter we're always
going to have that one
bad lifestyle nobody's gonna ever have a
perfect lifestyle
so we're here marching for adam tomido
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
will never be deleted
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
but there's honestly a lot of
segregation and a lot of
um i mean i don't even know how to put
it but
there is no equality for everybody here
in chicago and that's what we're out
here fighting for
laurie lightfoot likes to go ahead and
say that she's transparent
but she goes ahead and protects other
parts of her city better than she does a
little village
it's making sure that we stand up for
what's right and sometimes people will
go ahead and tell you you're wrong
and there's going to be a big amount of
people but that's why we're all here to
today
to make sure that the world knows that
adam toledo died in the hands of police
and he died innocently and he should
never have happened
what's your name brian martinez
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
up
hey
[Music]
guys
[Music]
wake up
they kind of clear out the middle
oh yeah
circle up
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
give me
okay
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
we are no longer talking about keeping
their positions abolishing the police is
what uh
justice for adam looks like we're
investing that money into our
communities is what it looks like
justice for adam
um being here and building community
with each other is what is justice for
adam
the same people that you see here every
single day these are the people who are
building community with you
if you look around the young people all
folks around
these are the people who are building
communities so when you look around
i just want to emphasize that like these
are the people who are gonna fight all
summer when we're going through these
protests
when we're looking at each other when
we're loving on each other when we're
thinking about adam when we're thinking
about all of these other young folks
that the police
have taken from us in front of us
is
that we are no longer talking about
representing police officers
that we are no longer talking about
abolishing the police we are demanding
that the police be abolished
thank you jj if we could please have the
two youth from royal
hi everybody can you guys hear me okay
so um
[Applause]
[Music]
um
i think
all right this is sick and sad
that a 13 year old who turned around and
put his hands up
was shot we do what the police officer
say
put your hands up adam did that and he
was shot
at first it was defined but now it's
seventh abolished let that sit in
he was in the seventh grade
that point in experience um that
couldn't even get
to be honest to
those who try to justify a 13 year old
being cute
you need to look in a mirror and really
really really
really have a conversation with yourself
they are here to serve and protect their
own with that badge
between the black that means the white
ones
because even nothing but a color
black or brown so as we stand here for
the victims
whose faces are on signs whose faces
are on posters let that let us remember
that we do this for them and we continue
this march in this fight for them
adam should be able to go on his summer
break right now
he should be able to go play with his
friends right now
but you want to know what adam is doing
right now
he's looking down on us he's watching
over us
he's proud of us not only to be sad
for the many victims of police violence
let them rest in power don't let their
names
[Music]
he's an organizer with
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what do we want
[Music]
[Applause]
um there's a lot of us over here
but it's a lot of people
and we're all united here because it's
enough police violence enough police
impunity
we're gonna have a few minutes of
silence
one minute of silence for mark nevadas
one minute of silence for adam
one minute of silence for anthony
alvarez
so three minutes of silence
so
so
[Music]
the neon red the yellow bass follow
their lead
and please stay behind the banners we
are respecting families and they are
leading this movement
[Music]
please respect the family
[Music]
[Music]
a hole
no justice no justice
no justice what do we want
when do we want it no justice
no justice no justice
i don't believe you no justice
please
today
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
we want you to
[Music]
[Music]
yourself
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
oh
[ __ ] glory lightboys
[Music]
oh
one two three four
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten eleven three four five six
seven eight nine
[Music]
one two three four five six seven eight
wow
[Applause]
out of your house
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it means everything to us we live in
this [ __ ] we live in gun violence every
day
police are not my daughter has been shot
at you know
this means everything to us out here
with our people representing
all mexican families all all families in
general
that have to live in this every day and
fear of dying our children died
can't turn to anybody all we have is
each other you have to live in the hood
to know what it is to live in the hood
we have each other you know my best
friend along with my friends that live
in the hood help me raise my kids
because someone has to explain to these
children why there's so much violence
and why all of our family members
are dying from gun violence humble parts
nothing has happened nothing has
happened except more and more people are
getting aggravated from no answers
seeing this family in pain well being in
a family that lost someone
in the riots last year there's never an
answer there's never justice
the police just pretends nothing ever
happened they think time heals all
wounds
these wounds aren't healed my kids are
growing up in this place
have to tell them the truth and i have
to teach them something